thank you all very much for coming to
our first highly publicized talk this
summer at the 8th summer of of Yei I'm
here to introduce my good friend Victor
Wong who is the CEO and and one of the
cofounders of paper G which actually
predates Yei they were actually founded
before why I even came into existence
that but then we just happened to to
sort of fall in together in the early
days of both our organization and his
organization and we were set up on on
above ashley's ice cream actually no he
started on Chapel Street 11:40 Chapel
Street was where they were set up not
cliff not far from where were you above
the above book trader and then they
moved over to 280 to 280 to York Street
before heading out to greener pastures
and in California Victor is probably in
addition to being one of the earliest
fellows is probably the most successful
running entrepreneur with the biggest
run rate right now of any of the
ventures out there in the in the working
world some other people decided to sell
their businesses before they got to the
skillet is this guy's decided to stay
with the business for the for the longer
haul it seems at least for now and try
and grow the team from from the
stupendous size that already is to
something even larger he was been quoted
by the New York Times as being the man
who to develop an ad engine to put Mad
Men out of business he has over a
hundred media companies as customers and
10,000 advertisers these include Hearst
Time Warner Cable Charter Communications
he's a noted author now has written for
a number of columns graduated in 2008 or
10
okay so he was gonna be a no.9 he did
come back he did come back and he did
finish two years later so kudos to him
and one of the most important fellows we
have especially on the west coast we
were Yale was actually the beneficiary
of a massive effort that Victor put on
just a few weeks ago he hosted a
conference of West Coast entrepreneurs
and investors in the Bay Area and 200
people came because that was the limit
of what of what the facility could hold
but there were a great many other people
who were told they couldn't come in they
were on a wait list and they were you
know outside bashing on the door but
they couldn't get in because of I guess
fire code or something so so Victor's
turned in to be a pretty important guy
in terms of bringing the whole Yale
entrepreneurial ecosystem into sharper
focus so with that I'm gonna turn it
over to up to Victor to talk to us today
thanks
great want to make sure this is on so
just get a little more context about
what we do before I kind of dive it a
little bit into startups and just some
advice and some thoughts that I prepared
I started the company with three other
co-founders while students here at Yale
we basically wanted to simplify the
process of bringing print advertisers
and publishers to digital which might
not sound too revolutionary now but at
the time print was the dominant force in
publishing advertising and digital was
certainly on the rise but hadn't yet
taken off yet in any significant way in
terms of material revenue so we started
a company with that in mind we built a
technology which is able to
automatically design ads and optimize
ads so we've really built an algorithm
to to really figure out what is good
design and how to apply that to
advertising so we had pretty nice quote
on the New York Times regarding that
effort but you know the journey of a
startup is it's quite long as you'll
find out as you guys continue to pursue
your ventures we got written up in the
New York Times I think back in 2010 or
11 and at the time the team was pretty
small it was about five to ten people
maybe a company now is about 60 people
headquartered in San Francisco with
offices now in Seattle and Vancouver so
we were all West Coasters now but today
the company's got the profitability last
year we did all this while raising
pretty minimal venture capital I think
to date we've raised a little over two
million dollars from seed stage
investors angel investors and we're able
to really make that work and we did this
back during the height of the financial
crisis which for some undergraduates
they probably were still in high school
when that was uncool things so we
basically were able to make a lot work
with very little which is a very useful
lesson I think obviously as
entrepreneurs so that's just a quick
background and I wanted to do something
a little bit different from some of
those talks at Gibbons at some points
for Yui and I wanted to kind of step
back and kind of talk about startups I
guess
from a bigger framework than just our
specific experiences though I certainly
will draw on some examples that we ran
into and an encounter but because this
is Yale because everyone here
I guess comes from a liberal arts kind
of background I wanted to kind of
examine the sort of experience from that
lens and just kind of dive a little bit
deeper in some questions that I
constantly find myself talking about and
thinking about it's kind of funny
because uh I guess liberal arts as I'm
as explained to me actually is the
definition of if you look back is kind
of the subject matter required in order
to be considered a free person way back
you know kind of think of Roman times
and so perhaps but take a little spin on
that I would consider the liberal arts
education for startups it's like the
minimum you need to free yourself of the
system and start your own company so
with that just a starting point when you
think about companies like what is the
point of a start-up what is the reason
why you're doing a company and I think
it's kind of an interesting question and
where do companies come from there's
always a creation myth for every company
so for example you know everyone talks
about how Google was started out of a I
think out of a garage you know two guys
just hacking it away on software when
the truth really was they actually came
up with the idea like a year or two
earlier worked on it for a while ended
up raising a million dollars in seed
money from Sequoia Capital and kleiner
perkins and then moved into a garage
because they wanted to replicate the
story of I think field at Packard which
started in a garage right so everyone
like here's all these great stories like
you may feel everyone here's seen the
movie The Social Network you know there
is a kernel of truth to all that based
on some accounts of the story but
ultimately a creation myth is born
around an idea and you know this is
similar for a new culture and everyone
has beliefs and the reason why this
exists with startups is very simply that
ultimately you need a very simple way to
convey your story right you need to
explain why do you exist how did all
this has come into being and so
oftentimes the reality of how companies
come together is not actually reflected
in the story
that you might hear about or read about
startups so you know for our company we
actually in many ways have evolved as a
company and our creation story certainly
has evolved over time and this is true
for every company so when you think
about your your company and you compare
it to you know these great stories how
you know one moment you know this great
idea came to you because like I mean
drew house didn't from Dropbox says like
he was on a bus and he realized he
wanted to follow sink has shared his
files I've heard him give this story
like several times but that's not really
the story like this you know but it's a
great way to explain what you do and
what the problem is and so I wouldn't
want you to mistake the creation myth
for the true work going into the
creation and the time it takes really to
build a company the creation myths are
really a byproduct of many generations I
guess going after the initial creation
as a simple way of conveying what's
going on so that's that's one kind of
construct I wanted to to talk about like
from the I guess liberal arts
perspective another one is really you
know what is the point of existing why
is why are we here why are we doing this
I think it's a very important question
to ask as a company not certainly as an
individual you should figure that out
but I think as a company should figure
this out and its founders because it's
something that you will grapple with
over time surprisingly a lot because
you'll get to decisions where like do we
sell the company now and there's been a
number of Yui fellows who've gone to
this decision-making tree and we've gone
through this several times you know so
are you motivated by the money are you
motivated by building a really big
company any company are you motivated by
seeing this particular idea come to
fruition and this is surprisingly the
motivations ultimately dictate a lot of
the actions and so having clarity on
that from beginning I think really
aligns you if your founders and so when
you get to those tough decisions it's
not like a hard conversation where you
realize that everyone was doing it for
different reasons and in fact that you
know you're not gonna get the outcome
that you wanted because everyone's going
to go their own ways so I think you
really do have to ask yourself and
getting and throughout like what is it
about this that you're doing because if
you really want to see an idea through
hippedy may not be the right idea
because you know if you really care
about a specific idea taking hold in the
world why are you hitting like that's
not going to get you closer to your goal
but if your goal is to ultimately find a
successful business idea or business
model the pivoting could be a very good
tactic and a successful tactic but these
are all comes down to those motivations
and so I think a lot of people don't
spend time it's really just like
individually you don't think necessarily
spending as much time in undergrad think
about these things and so as a company
it's not surprising that a lot of
companies don't think about why they're
starting the company as a result they
run into many years of life well what
are we doing how we're going to do this
like how much longer are we gonna work
on this which we do in this situation so
I think getting to the really the core
that is very important for everyone
another thing I actually I think about a
lot is this kind of this notion of the
social contract like what is it why when
you why do people join companies first
of all right
why do you as an employee join a company
why do you start a company what is your
obligation as a company to your
employees and vice-versa and this is
just like you know if anyone that takes
social theory or social sciences
thinking about like what is the original
social contract why do people join
society is like what do you benefit by
being in a society versus being an
individual and I think the answer
generally for that is you obviously get
stability you're getting shelter order
better chance at survival and so as
individuals like 9 Mutombo startups but
joining a company and prudential as an
employee you know that's probably what
you're looking for to in many ways
you're looking for stable income you're
looking for career track you're looking
for a opportunity to learn something and
ultimately you know advance within an
organization probably and so I'm just
thinking about your company from a
societal standpoint I think is a very
interesting way to look at it because it
starts getting to the heart of you know
what are your values so for example
thinking about why would a person join
your company versus
joining Google or Goldman Sachs is it
that they're motivated by money is that
what they want from a company is it that
they want to learn a lot and become an
entrepreneur themselves or simply just
gain a lot of skills for exposures to
different things and so understanding
what that exchange of values is for when
they sign up you're come to your company
is very important because that will help
you recruit people and motivate people
but it also you start thinking about
what is your obligation as a founders
here to your company we have 60
employees we have a actually a
remarkably low turnover rate in terms of
voluntary turnover meaning number of
people that have left our company
because they've chosen to I think the
number is something like two or three
people maybe four like definitely less
than a handful of people have ever left
paper G because they've decided that
they wanted to go do something else
meanwhile you know we've certainly
terminated folks over the course of the
of the company for bad performance
cultural fits and you know legality
issues perhaps so there's a lot of
reasons why but you have to add then ask
yourself like well if you expect your
employees to give you two weeks notice
if they're gonna leave for another
opportunity
what is your obligation as an employer
to the employee should you give them two
weeks severance is that fair are you
obligated to give them four weeks
severance doesn't that seem unfair to
the company that you have to give more
than the employee has to give to you are
you okay with that do you want a social
safety net for your employees how are
you gonna convey that to your employees
and so like in many ways the the beliefs
of the founder is very much shaped the
company and the culture that it builds
and ultimately the the people it keeps
because it will attract the people that
share the same values and ultimately
will push away people that don't embrace
those values or will demoralize the
people that don't have the same values
and so if you do not have a strong
understanding of what you believe in
what you value you're going to either
make at worse inconsistent decisions
because as founders you can't agree on
what to do in a situation and so every
time it's different
or and so people actually start
questioning if there's any stability in
the company or whether or not they can
trust that the system is fair or
you know you really basically make
decisions that create a very very
conflicting and harsh environment that
people don't want to work in because
they find your values off-putting and
it's not a place that they want to park
their career in so thinking about what
is the social contract that you're
offering your employee uses something I
think most people don't think about
obviously when your first or your
company are much more focused on what
are we working on and like how are the
founders gonna work but it starts very
quickly becoming and a contract among
the founders a contract with the
investors and a contract with your
employees whether it's a written
contract or not at the end of the day
you are making an agreement and not
having firm values thought-out can very
much cost you down the road I've seen
this countless times with other
companies and with our companies there's
certainly been times where we've been
challenged but we'd have been fortunate
that the founders share the same values
and so have been able to make consistent
decisions about what to do and what
situations and over time as a result
that has built the narrative and the
history within the company of what we
would do and so employees can find
consistency and stability by working
with us rather than working at a company
where you know it's whatever the founder
says goes because he's either upset that
day or not so something's worth thinking
about
even this early into the company's life
is this kind of contractor you're gonna
you're gonna provide people you have to
think about any time you're forming a
society or I you have to think about
ownership and governance how are you
guys gonna resolve decisions what's the
fair mechanism of doing so
so founder equity splits are a very
common issue that everyone here will
probably face that they haven't started
their company yet or will fight over
even after you could agree to it
years later very few companies I think
get it right exactly right the first
time and that's because you really don't
know among the founders who is that
committed and that's because you might
feel committed now but a year from now
of it of grueling work I just start up
you might realize this is not for you
right and so you might decide to walk
off and so is it
fair that you know you have as much
equity probably not so you never really
know until after the fact whether that
you guys got a right or wrong and or by
how much and those mechanisms to balance
that and I'm sure why I will cover that
for you but just thinking about
fundamentally what you guys think is
what is fairly what's you know as a
society like is a everyone gets paid
equally model the model that you want to
have in your company is it the person
that's contributing the most gets the
most how would you determine that right
how are you going to determine that from
the initial beginning without all the
perfect information of knowing how
people are going to work together so you
very much actually have to think about
this from a societal value standpoint
what do you believe it what do you think
what is the world that you want to
create because that's the world that
you're gonna be living in every day so
thinking about the society that you're
putting together and the mechanisms for
resolution differences is it gonna just
be you have to work it out with you know
whoever it is it founder the ultimate
arbiter is there a policy that you guys
can eventually have to put in place as
you evolve as a company you'll probably
go through a natural evolution of like
well will the side that has become by
the founder but as you hire more more
people that's just not possible you have
to start putting institutions in place
you have to start thinking about oh well
I don't I can't be involved in every
decision so how am I going to build a
framework for others to do it how are
they going to understand that so think
about your startup as the company or as
the as the society that you want to
build and live in because that's the
reality that you're going to be
occupying for day in and day out more
than anything else and everyone's going
to model and your company their behavior
after how you conduct yourself and how
you want the company to be so as
founders you basically have power to
shape that very early on and if you
don't get it right very early on it
starts becoming much more difficult
later off to change and generally
involves removing a lot of people in
order to change it because in the end of
the day you know rules and such even if
they're codified and written down don't
really matter it's basically one of the
people want to follow it and so I think
it's important to figure out those
values and attract people with the same
values otherwise there's going to be
spending a lot of your time fixed
problems that you wish that you probably
could have avoided another thing that I
think you know in the liberal arts
tradition that you kind of grapple with
a lot of time this is is ethics and I
actually think this is the most
interesting reason why I at least find
startups in business in general
fascinating and why there's never a
boring day really working at a start-up
and that's basically you deal with
constantly challenges between the
individual you know good and the
collective good and I'm talking about
situations plenty of situations that
we've run into like if you know do you
do you late do you choose to lay off a
bunch of a lot of people who are non
performers or terminate them let's say
or is it better to lower everyone's
salary in order to make the next payroll
right which one is better is it fair to
punish the ones who work really hard or
wait but at the same time perhaps keep
everyone and perhaps keep the team unity
or is it better to cut the people who
aren't contributing as much right that's
a challenge that a lot of companies face
and you'll no doubt only face at some
point you'll start thinking about issues
like if someone is individually
productive but let's say he's not a
cultural fit because for whatever reason
you know he has a different work ethic
isn't shouldn't same values he just
doesn't get along with other wrong other
people do you fire that person right he
is making other people upset he is
making other people unproductive so is
that fair to him to fire him even though
he's doing his job very well it's it's a
classic issue especially in a case of a
start-up where you were relying on very
technical talent or not a very technical
but very particular talent that's in
short supply and that person has more
leeway perhaps to be difficult because
they're not as replaceable so how do you
handle that situation
another situation that startups run into
very typically and why they get a lot of
flack I think for the current gender
balance in startups is oftentimes after
you get to a certain stage as a startup
you know you want to hire people so you
can't just hire among your friends in
this demographic I'm making the
assumption most early 20s mid 20s
and so you run insert you start trying
to hire more experienced people which
means they're gonna be older and so you
start running into things like oh well I
have X dollars in the bank
so this hire has to be like the right
hire otherwise like I just wasted all
this money I won't have any more money
to fix this mistake if I make a bad hire
mistake oh this person also let's say is
recently married is female maybe is
thinking about having a kid
well happens if she has a kid and wants
to take time off for maternity leave
right well how do you handle that what's
fair to who if she takes three months
off right paid or unpaid even that could
be disastrous for a start-up because
they no longer have the resources to
execute against the plan that they set
out to do so do you let that factor into
your decision making a lot of companies
do and I don't think it's right but it's
a legal impact but that's
it's a reality it's a reality that
you'll start facing you know there are
rules that you guys are probably unaware
of because you're too young that
particularly protect older and older
employees as regards to termination and
severance and all these other factors
like issues that don't have anything to
do with your product you probably aren't
even thinking about now but you'll start
realizing oh well if I hire an older
person is gonna cost me more money a
younger person cost less they probably
have more hours available because they
don't have a family to take care of and
you know if I need to terminate them
it's not gonna be much of a hassle is
that the sort of company that you want
to work at that's the company that
you're creating if you in fact are
creating that policy but you're not
probably not thinking about it
explicitly at least initially but I can
tell you that there are conversations
that happen all the time in Silicon
Valley where decisions are made probably
on on a very shaky legal basis but
certainly on the basis that the company
needs to survive they cannot take a
chance right this is a lot of times why
people will say VCS are more likely the
fun men than women in many ways is among
many other advice among many other
reasons that they might not but these
are the fundamental questions of what
you believe and what world you're gonna
create because it's very easy to say oh
this company is has bad ethics and bad
values but when you're in charge you
really can't blame anyone else it's your
decision and so that's the world that
you want to live in that's the world
that you can make so fundamentally like
every day as the founders you'll be put
in the position of a decision maker
where you will have to make a trade-off
you'll have to decide how does that
decision impact downstream for your
company and the whole world if you want
to if you think that you have that much
of an impact but you have to think about
that constantly as founders another very
common example of challenges as we said
we've we've run into certainly as a I
think b2b business and I think probably
lesser extent abuse
but and this is a situation recently
highlighted by Elon Musk where his
company if you guys aren't familiar he
started Tesla PayPal SpaceX all these
big companies and most recently at
SpaceX he alleges that he got passed
over for a billion dollar contract with
the Air Force because the Air Force
official who was in charge of the
procurement process wanted a job at
SpaceX and he said no but the
competition who was bidding for it gave
the job that official so right after the
contract was awarded the government
official moved over to that competing
bid right doesn't sound particularly
ethical questionably in terms of
legalities because it's a public
official but it's something that we
actually see all the time in the private
sector we have paper G there's been at
least two incidences where I could think
of where VP at very large tech companies
have offered to do a deal with us but
we'd have to hire they've insinuated
we've had to hire them afterwards
because they gave us a deal right so you
have to ask yourself well okay what's
actually wrong with that situation right
like if your company needs the money to
survive is that okay if this is if your
company just would benefit from the deal
do you need to do this and what's the
harm if you do it right like you can
probably rationalize that and say oh
well the company needs it without the
money the company won't exist so
therefore who's who's thinking about all
these silly little ethical things but
the the next thing that you start
realizing is one you started to bring in
people into your organization who
clearly have a high disregard for the
interests of the organization that they
work for
so that's someone that you want to work
at your company as a VP right like do
you want them to be representing your
company because they're probably gonna
sell you down the road if they just sold
a lost one on the other hand you know
it's a big contract like the only
dollars a lot of money so you know I
wouldn't kid yourself into thinking that
by going into start-up and you know you
have this ideal version of how business
runs that you're gonna be insulated for
these problems in fact your guys you're
now running these problems much more
than if you worked at a big company
because you're worked at a big company
you won't necessarily be asked
make a decision on any of these
questions you might see parts and bits
of it but you'll never have to make the
final call or decide what's ultimately
acceptable and these were all things
that we as a company had faced over the
last six years and started the company
and we've grappled with in some of the
decisions I think we got right and some
decisions you know we've still
questioned like was that ultimately the
best trade-off in values for everyone
involved
so it's really tough obviously to get it
all right but I think having that
foundation of values is probably the
most important I can think of somewhere
over all the scenarios like that I've
seen witness either firsthand or through
friends have seen examples like you know
that you're about to run out of money in
two weeks okay but you need to make a
key hire you think that money is coming
in two weeks do you tell your key hire
that you're about to make that you're
about to run out of money right don't
you think it's unfair to hire someone
who's gonna quit his job to join your
company and you're not gonna be able to
make payroll in a few weeks or a few
months but you might need this key hire
in order to get that money what do you
do this is pretty common or you know
investors are allowed to make an
investment in your company someone says
they might sue you but they haven't
formally sued you yet do you tell the
new investors that you might be under a
lawsuit soon but you if you don't get
the money your company won't exist once
again pretty common actually
you'll be surprised these are all things
that might sound like will happen to
someone else but I can guarantee you
police one of these problems is gonna
happen to you in the next 18 months of
starting your company if you are still
around 18 months
yeah it's worked a little bit about
culture I think a common adage in
Silicon Valley that I believe very much
is the people that you that you hire is
the company that you build it's the
culture that you have altima we have so
I generally believe that you need to
hire people based on cultural fit and
alignment certainly a skill
is a big part of it but I've certainly
learned from experience that hiring the
right person based on skills solely is a
very short side in a limited decision
ultimately people that just don't get
along culturally are eventually gonna
leave or they are gonna drive others
people to leave and nothing that's
something to think about which is you
get to decide as a founder of who stays
and who goes right if you keep somebody
that's individually productive but is
highly toxic or acidic or just like
absolutely bad for the for the
environment you will ultimately see
people quit right and so you've
basically made the decision that by
keeping this guy who's an [ __ ] that
this guy who everyone likes maybe he's
gonna leave because why would you want
to stay and tolerate this work
environment so whether you make the
explicit choice or not you will have the
side of that who comes and who goes and
that's why I think a good reason why
we've had such low turnover at our
company is that we've been very
proactive about ensuring that we keep
the people that we want and as a result
very few people you know ever ever think
about leaving our company over Aquatics
extended time period and you know the
last thing before I wanted to kind of
keep this brief since I know people
probably have questions
happy to dive into all some more
anecdotes but just thinking about
success like what is the meaning of life
or why are you at what would make you
happy right what is this all for how
will you know that you're successful for
some people you know it is like building
the company for over 50 years until you
you know you die or until you give it to
someone else that's their goal they want
to build a legacy for other people in
the technology space in particular you
know it's about the quick flip it's
about putting points on the boards about
winning and based on what you want
that's how you should decide who you
work with because if you do not have
that same alignment you know at least
one of you is not going to have success
I can guarantee you right because you
guys are going to have very different
ideas board to take their company so
think about that before you start your
company like why are you doing this how
will I know that I am successful
when I get there because if you don't if
you don't know where you're going very
common adage is any road will take you
there it's true you can easily it's true
for your career if you decide to be to
be employee and it's true as a start-up
founder half your conversations
post-graduation with friends if you guys
choose to be on trapeze will be about
then asking what should I do my job I
don't know what I want I don't know
where where to go right and if that's
that's bound to happen to you as an
entrepreneur if you don't know what you
want your company know on set especially
so you know obviously I'm just raising a
lot of questions I'm not giving you guys
many answers this is the the nature I
guess of local arts may be happy to
obviously opine and in fact I one of my
friends from Yale once said and I think
it's pretty pretty witty which is the
one thing he learned from his liberal
arts education is that not knowing
anything about anything hasn't ever
stopped him from saying something about
everything so I think it's and I think
it's actually really applies actually to
be entrepreneurs that truth is you guys
probably don't know anything about
anything
but what liberal arts teach you
obviously is you know the questions to
ask so you can learn and it also teaches
you to have an opinion even if it's not
reformed because the worst thing you can
have fee as an entrepreneur is being a
person without a point of view I think
the Beatles probably called it a nowhere
man you know know where man has no
perspective that's not know where he's
going
it's if you do not have a point of view
of how the world should be you are not
going to change the world you're not
going to be able to get people to follow
you to change the world so if you are
right or wrong you won't know until
after you do it and you probably don't
know everything that you need to know to
succeed yet but you need to have an
opinion without an opinion you basically
are working on nothing so I think you
should definitely think about although
obviously all the questions I kind of
laid out before you start your company
but
you need to think about what is
something that you have an opinion on
and what are you gonna do about it I
think that's kind of the best starting
point as entrepreneurs so that's a my
prepared remarks I'm trying to perhaps
be more academic since I'm video but
happy to take questions about anything
relating to startups or about our
company or my background but you'll hear
enough about from I think future
speakers about their companies and their
successes so I thought it'd be good to
kind of lay the groundwork please for
you guys